you mentioned RFK the guy you met what
do you think about uh some of the other
candidates outside of Joe Biden in the
Democratic party RFK Jr
what do you think of him as a candidate
I've met him we once had dinner and we
have a number of friends in common which
is what makes this a little more awkward
but I think his campaign is basically
sort of like a chaos candidacy to raise
awareness and maybe raise money either
for his book or his anti-vaccine
organization children's defense fund I
believe it's called I think there's some
reporting that Steve Bannon really liked
the idea of him running as a Democrat
again to just generate chaos
I don't find it super interesting I
don't find it worthy of that much
discussion uh smart guy nice guy
has been doing anti-vaccine work that I
don't find particularly inspiring so
it's not just anti-covered vaccine it's
bro more broader he's been in that space
long before the covid vaccines yeah yeah
I don't find it super interesting well
he also wrote the book uh
the real Anthony fauci is that the name
of the book did he write that that's I
didn't I don't know that's I'm not sure
about that I'm aware of that book I
didn't know he wrote it I think I did
but it's been uh uh it's been on my
reading list to get uh I've been trying
to get a good balanced reading list
about uh the covet pandemic to
understand what the hell happened and um
anytime I start to try to go into that
place it's just I'm exhausted by it well
it's interesting to me that you wouldn't
wait longer before delving into those
books to have maybe a more
clear hindsight
but I think this is a pretty good time
you don't think so like this this is
uh it depends on your goals if you're
thinking of it as a historical event yes
you should probably wait longer but if
you're thinking about like understanding
what is broken about our system that we
responded so poorly
that there was so much division what is
broken about our political system that
um it didn't unite us it divided us
who's to blame there's probably a lot of
different narratives but I feel like the
more you learn about this the the better
you can understand I read um I'm just
Vladimir Putin I read like five
biographies already maybe more
um just it helps to really understand
the people involved the organizations
evolved I don't know everything from the
scientists to the political leaders
um
it felt like the blog posts and the
tweets didn't quite Captivate no one of
the things I read a ton I don't read any
like modern political books so I don't
read the Memoirs of elected officials I
don't read any I just feel like I get
enough of it in my job so my reading
list is just other things it's history
it's narrative non-fiction economics
Etc and that's my bias because I'm so
overloaded with a lot of the stuff
you're talking about I haven't read any
of Obama's books I didn't read John
Bolton's book or you know I I don't read
any of that stuff although I'm sure
there there is value to be gleaned from
it